there's been some recent casting news
surrounding the Batman and since we as a
nation just care so much about who plays
Batman and all the other characters and
Gotham let's talk about everything we
know about the Batman right now on the
ketchup
so the Batman is scheduled to hit
theaters in June of 2021 and Warner
Brothers has recently confirmed two
major castings including Paul Dano as
the Riddler
Danah was recently nominated for an Emmy
for his role in the certified fresh'
escape it's Ana Mora and he should make
a fantastic Riddler I want to be a part
of your dream the Warner Brothers
recently confirmed that zoe kravitz who
has been slaying it on HBO's big little
lies has been cast as Selina Kyle aka
Catwoman it's a role she coincidentally
also voiced in a certified fresh' Lego
Batman movie if you didn't already know
that so if she sounds like a Catwoman
and looks like a Catwoman Animated then
she's probably gonna be a great Catwoman
they of course will join Robert
Pattinson as Bruce Wayne and Batman but
when Roberts casting was officially
announced back in May there was some
backlash from fans shocker
some fans were skeptical largely due to
Roberts most popular movie projects aka
The Twilight Saga because apparently you
can't be a vampire and a superhero in
the same lifetime it's like a drug to me
but now it seems optimism is prevailing
friends thanks to stellar performances
from Pattinson and certified fresh'
indie hits like 2017 good time and the
Sears High Life not to mention the
awards buzz surrounding certified fresh'
the lighthouse which opens this weekend
now as far as other cast members go it
had been heavily rumored that Jonah Hill
was going to be playing a villain but
variety has reported that he has passed
on the film it's also been rumored that
up to six villains could appear in the
movie with twoface and the Mad Hatter
being mentioned which is Loki very
exciting because we've never really seen
Mad Hatter on the big screen yet and
with all these Batman villains rumored
to make an appearance it feels like
there's gonna be more tension in this
movie than the Thanksgiving table back
at home and while it seems very unlikely
that Pattinson Batman and walking
Phoenix's Joker will ever meet Jared
Leto's version of Joker could possibly
make a comeback during Pattinson to run
in the Batsuit also worth noting is that
Westworld star Jeffrey Wright has been
cast to play Commissioner Gordon and Joe
Manganiello was at one time expected to
play masters
and deathstroke after appearing in a
post-credits scene in justice league as
a new recruit to Lex Luthor's super
villain team but this was all back when
the Batman was in vain' Alex hands so
there's no word yet on if Joe will
actually be involved going forward
and speaking of ben affleck he was
actually set to star in and direct the
batman but things have changed
drastically since 2016 he ultimately
dropped out completely and matt reeves
known for 2017 certified fresh' war for
the Planet of the Apes was hired to
write direct and co-produced the film so
now Ben will have more time to watch Tom
Brady bad humans as far as the story
goes we do know that the Batman will
likely be the start of a trilogy but
it's unclear where and how the film fits
into the DC EU and while we'll see a
younger version of Bruce Wayne it is not
necessarily going to be an origin story
in fact it sounds like Reeves may be
sticking to a similar tone the
applicants going for Reeves told
Hollywood Reporter back in January it's
very much a point-of-view driven noir
Batman tale it's more Batman in his
Detective Mode than we've seen in the
films and now it's time for you to play
detective who else would you like to see
cast in a Batman and who is your
favorite Batman tell us all your
thoughts in the comments section and
good news our first book rotten movies
that we love is out right now it
celebrates 101 movies on the greened end
of the spectrum that you should totally
check out as always thank you for
watching to catch up and if you liked
this episode and you want to see more
subscribe and click that Bell icon I'm
now surprised and I'll see you guys next
time